i ask you will how's family life my life
is
yeah i guess this connects to the
formula shortage let's talk about the
formula shortage you got the story from
the daily mail this is what america
looks america last looks like gop rep
fumes at pallets of baby formula being
sent to border centers for illegal
migrants while american babies go
without amid nationwide shortage so she
posted this picture said she got from a
border uh uh patrol agent the first
photo is from the ursula processing
center at the u.s border shelves packed
with baby formula my favorite thing
about it you're going to love this is
there are signs that say i think it says
like 84 let me actually i don't know if
they have you can see it
what does it say it says like 84 times
26 equals 216 2016 and people are like
it says 2016 it's clearly a very old
photograph what and it's like dude
they're talking about the amount of baby
formula they have everybody who says
this is fake doesn't have a child or
does not purchase formula like it's it's
you know i mean but are they really
giving it to illegal immigrants instead
i'm sure they i mean i'm sure they have
like a backup supply right like they've
probably got their supply line set up
but here's the thing to understand right
there's
a lot of it's not the hardest to find
like the standard issue formula right
now right there's sort of like the very
basic like most companies that make
formula and you know have some sort of
like formula that is the default close
to similar to breast milk formula right
and that's usually that's still
available in a lot of places and even if
you can't find the brand you've been
used to you can find like a version of
that the problem is that some babies
need these like very niche specialty
formulas because they have very special
nutritional needs they just don't
tolerate the normal stuff and those
babies are stuck there might be like two
companies making that particular br that
particular type of formula and they're
scrambling and it's like they can't eat
anything else
and i mean there's there's people saying
how's milk right oh no you they can't
they can't eat anything else this is
what they eat yeah and goats of milk
yeah like they're they're scrambling to
find it and wait horse milk course milk
right um you're on to something we tried
it you know so i mean this is a this is
a real thing like you know our on our
end like you know we've we have to use
formula it's not that's not a choice we
need to yeah um and we've we're lucky
that our little elizabeth tolerates like
the standard issue normal close to
brexit formula so we've been able to
switch but we're about to we've already
switched once right we switched away
from similac to like this amazon house
brand now we're gonna have to switch
away from the amazon house brand because
that's out of stock so we're switching
into like something else
um and you're just wondering like what's
the next thing that's gonna go out of
stock right like when's the when is this
gonna end and and they're gonna get this
plant they shut down this like the
single most
you know biggest production baby formula
plant in the country over some health
issues and they haven't reopened it
and it's like there's there's there's
problems like we've empty shelves of
formulas well
i just found out that cow's milk has no
vitamin c but horse milk actually has
lots of vitamin c
well thank you for the suggestion good
suggestion yeah
well i mean so so but i've seen a lot of
posts from uh you know we made we
actually made the joke just breastfeed
and then i remember we had on but they
were like what did mothers do before
nestle was incorporated but i understand
not everybody can or doesn't nurses well
yeah the answer is yeah wet nurses right
like unless
you would go down to the town forum and
there would be women who could
breastfeed and you would hand your child
over to through the woman whose job it
was to literally breastfeed everything
so women need to create breastfeed pods
if they have a baby
no joke i mean i i
i don't know what else you're going to
do if your baby's starving you're going
to do what you got to do right we have
the equivalent some form of that in the
la latte league which is women who
donate excess breast milk which is such
an amazing idea this is an international
league where you can go to almost any
community there's one in frederick
there's a bunch in this area and you
need to hook up with that and see if
there's women who are willing to donate
because some of them have extra so i
think that's probably the best source
for people who are really struggling to
find formula pediatricians say not to
make it but i also know that
pediatricians get a lot of kickbacks
from these companies to recommend these
formulas do you think a person can live
off of nothing but human breast milk
uh probably not an adult probably not an
adult yeah it doesn't body builders buy
it yeah but they're dumb i don't know
it's it's but yeah i mean there's people
who are like and then that doesn't sort
of solve they're like some babies who
can't tolerate breast milk they really
do need very specific things well i mean
but let's be real will
you know i don't think your child is
deserving of it because there are
oppressed marginalized babies right
there was somebody who did you consider
that we tweeted out that i was like
deserve it well we tweeted out that i
was well stocked on formula right
because like we we i've seen this coming
this has been in the news so you know we
got like maybe two months of formula in
the just in the pantry
and somebody somebody you know tweeted
me it's like what about other people's
babies you're being selfish like do you
do you think your child is more
important than other people's children i
was like
yes
i do care to me
yes
other people's children are other
people's job my child is my job i just
love that question do you think your
kids are more important
yes yes of course
yeah no i mean look it's a serious
problem we can talk about all the other
inflationary pressures people are facing
but a shortage of formula for the
families who really need i mean that's
devastating that is i mean it's like the
only food like imagine going to the
grocery store and there's nothing there
that's not right like that that's the
equivalent for these children who like
can eat one thing and that's their
entire diet now hold on hold on that's
an unbelievable scam
yeah we got these photos right here's a
photo from the store of the empty baby
formula section explain to those who
don't understand it looks like there is
formula
what's the
can't parents just buy these formulas so
first off it means you have to switch
right like no matter what so like
there's there's only one brand that
actually has canisters right that's the
it looks like enfamil which is on the
top row then you have like that that
means so if you're if your kid is used
to and tolerates some other formula like
similac which is the other major brand
or like the house brands like you don't
really like switching formula because
your baby tolerates and it works you
want to stick with the same one um
but that so basically it means like it
doesn't matter if you've been using
similac or any other brand guess what
you the only thing available today is
enfamil and over moreover not all the
infamous up there so if your baby
tolerates a very specific like kind of
ski type of formula say one that's like
lactose free for sensitive or some you
know there's there's there's alimentum
there's a divide variety well that might
not be there so guess what the formula
your baby tolerates isn't at the store
so you need to go to another store
um you just drive and moreover it's like
you know there's there's not that much
on the shelf right there right like
you know the the similac thing that
little the bottle that's like nothing
because the powder is actually where you
actually can feed your kid in bulk right
like most the way most people end up
making formulas you have you get the
powder in bulk you add water and you mix
it and so like one canister powder will
last you like a week right that little
like thing that the bottle on the middle
shelf right that'll last you
uh
eight you know 12 hours right that's
like 12 hours of food we got to make wet
nurses great again right like apparently
so that's that that's a serious that's a
problem right like it's not that
you know most babies will probably be
able to tolerate one of the formulas
that's on the top shelf but that's not
good and it really needs to not get
worse right and then for some babies
that's a huge problem i'm wondering like
how often
do
do societies go through this period
where
there's like this fall off you know what
i mean a strife i suppose we can
make references to straws out
generational theory or the fourth
turning or whatever but i'm wondering
you know
all of a sudden we had this luxury that
is that is formula we used to need wet
nurses that was the normal human thing
we invented formula we invented a
process by which we could feed babies
and now all of a sudden it's a shock to
our system that we don't have it if we
were still doing traditional wetner
stuff nobody would be nobody would care
about this so it seems like the
developments and everything we've had
being ripped away gas prices through the
roof you can't drive anymore it's hard
to work it's hard to buy a house
food shortages diesel shortages baby
formula shortages cat food shortages
it's like we we reach this plateau of
luxury and now we're being dropped off
and like i'm wondering does that happen
often it seems like it's part of the
system of growth because i was thinking
last night like what if i just disposed
of my feces in the woods i'd be like
well it wouldn't be a problem as a
one-off
i could do it one time but it's not
sustainable and as the city grows people
not everyone can just go dump their
waste in the woods and i think this is
those that start out their windows yeah
exactly when you have a few enough
people it's fine just send it over there
over the hill over there and you have to
think about it but
you know once society grows to a point
you can't like wetner says maybe you
could argue the wet nurses no longer
made sense i think in this society they
could mandatory milking well what nurses
i mean it's it's not economical right
like you you know as opposed to paying
it in terms of
i mean but the thing is it's not fragile
yeah i'll tell you this right now i'm
willing to bet women who are over
producing are are making a good penny oh
i'm sure they are because they're that
you've already had women who sell their
breast milk to bodybuilders
and i guess the idea is they're like
human breast milk is formulated
perfectly for humans so bodybuilders buy
it and they're like you know they want
it but you also have mothers who buy it
when they when they can't produce
because they prefer uh breast milk over
a formula i think the demand the demand
is obviously through the roof so you
know we joke about wet nurses but it's
it's probably in full swing right now it
is happening could well be yeah well i
don't know isn't it interesting that
this new development and don't get me
wrong i love science i think that
scientific advances are amazing and part
of the reason we require formula is
because we're able to deliver and
sustain babies as young as 21 weeks
but it is very interesting that this
scientific development is pushing us
away from other people it is keeping us
from relying on somebody like a wet
nurse and of course you want to be tied
to another person but it's dissolving
the community that's the answer tied to
the other person right no more removal
of umbilical cords until that's right i
agree absolutely you don't gotta worry
about formula the baby is just placenta
mommy eats the cheeseburger and the baby
grows yes i can speak like form formula
is a wonderful invention there's a lot
of people who rely on it for a reason uh
you know like the in terms of
you know reliably i mean because like
you know breastfeeding is not for
everybody right like it can be in a real
real struggle for people for us we
absolutely needed to switch to formula
like it wasn't it wasn't really an
option by the time like we were we made
that decision for sure i just mean
i ask what does that mean for our
civilization if planes for instance all
of a sudden the cost of flying is
getting really really difficult it's
going up for a lot of people
what happens when these
inventions these uh these standards that
you know we'd call them luxuries 100
years ago they become standards what
happens when we lose those are we in for
a long fall we're talking about
electricity maybe the central electric
grid we're so used to that if that goes
out yeah it's like a jenga jenga tower
if you take out the wrong block at the
wrong time
well you're seeing the blocks of diesel
because when with diesel going up diesel
is how we get all the products that go
on our store shelves and you pull out
one pin and i don't think that people
understand this because we've lived such
fluffy protected lives for so long now
and i remember there was a point in time
where you could watch anything on your
computer you could order anything
through doordash and you could go to the
store and get everything and i remember
thinking this is amazing we're
incredibly lucky it's all about to fall
down and i don't remember why i thought
that but pretty soon after that we ended
up with kovid we started to have supply
chain disruption and i'm starting to
think that was the peak i don't know if
it's all downhill for or for us or not
but
it's not looking good and i think it's
only going to get worse tim you asked
earlier about our society and how if it
frequently happens like this kind of
this kind of cycle or this kind of thing
and it's like yeah we can think of
america as a society but realistically
the globe is a society the entire
species is citing and starvation and
famine is prevalent in the 1900s you not
only have the voldemort which is human
cause you've got the cultural revolution
in china which i don't know how many
millions of people died from starvation
because of that and right today we'll
talk about um
over there where we're bombing in yemen
i think that the americans are involved
in the saudis bombing yemen
yeah
so like famine it's all it's almost
always there and if you're on the wrong
end of the stick thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you